North or something like 200 whatever. It's
like the closest saltwater crocs. Yeah,
they keep a track like you know,
they're pretty visual and about how,
where they are, what rivers they would
be because they get a warn. People like,
don't swim here. Some people don't
listen, they're stupid and they die.
But like a crocs not going to just sort
of give you an exploratory bite like a
great white might and review. They're
going to snatch you and there, you know,
and they're not going to get the
surfboard and the way from the underbite,
you know they're gonna.
There was a horrible story that I read it.
I think it was in national
geographic about this.
These two people that were kayaking in
the river in Africa and this guy was guy
went with him. Did you? This
might be a different story.
I don't know. What do you,
what story did you hear?
This one was like,
these two guys were going to do a first
descent down this thing and they were
contacting another guy who had
done that river, an American guy.
And the American guy was like, I
can't miss this, the I got to do this,
I gotta do that whole river.
And then the three of them got into
this zone where they're just crocs
everywhere in the river was real slow
and wide. And as soon as they got there,
all the river, all the crocs came off the
river bank and they were like, oh shit,
there's like tons of them.
And this guy's theory was to take his
helmet and throw it off to the side.
So it would be like
movement and distract them.
And they'd attack that and he paddled
up the shore and all three of them got
together and the American guy was on the
right side and the other two guys where
you've got, and they were so close,
they like the guy in the middle,
like we couldn't really paddle. He
would just kind of like, you know,
trying to move along with them.
And so they figured if the bigger we are,
the bigger we look and more intimidating,
like maybe we'll be okay.
1518 foot crop comes up, grabs
the guy, takes him out of his,
pulls him out of his car, disappears.
They never seen him again.
His backpack floats up and then his
stuff's floating down downstream.
The other two guys get out of the water.
And um,
I think I'm telling the story pretty
good because I read it like five times
online too.
And they got other water and then there's
a little village just down and there
was a little, um, a
bridge over. And they had,
there were some boats when the boats were
all dry docked and they went down and
in broken English there was one person
that could talk to him or whatever and
they said,
you know,
our boats are not in the water
because there's too many crops here.
Like we know not to go on the water
because they were like, we need a boat.
We got to find his body. We got
to try and save him, you know,
and then they went to this bridge
and wash this stuff like float by.
That's the same story. Yeah, it's,
and the guy wasn't supposed to be on
the trip and there was about the gut,
the Kayak flipping and then pulling
his body out under the Kayak.
Yeah. Brutal. They're monsters. It's a,
there's a show called Diana started.
They really are.
This is a show called uncharted
by, uh, you've seen that show.
My friend Jim Shockey is a Florida.
Yeah,
that's 15 foot fucking
alligator they found in Florida,
strolling across the golf course and
the next day they found a giant snake,
a giant rattlesnake strolling
across the golf course.
Look at the size of that thing I fed,
you know, I was friends with Steve Irwin,
so he said, go to look at the size
of that thing on a golf course.
Here's the thing, I, I,
I think there's a misconstrued
misconception about the crocs.
And they actually talked about this,
cause I used to be friends with Steve
Irwin before he passed away. He taught.
He actually had me hand feed a 13 foot
crock and scariest thing I've ever done
in my life. Terrified. Why would
you do that? And I dunno. He,
he told me, you know, you got to
feed a crock. Fuck that. Kelly,
you're ready Mike. You a feed
crock. You got to Viagra.
So for two nights so crazy for
two nights I had nightmares.
Look at it.
What is this guy doing it?
That one I told you I saw this a
few weeks ago. He's feeding them.
Why is he doing these things?
Look at their heads.
Oh Man. Good Lord. And
these are wild crocs.
Well they look pretty like they know
this guy going to feed them something.
They know something in that bad man.
Look at the heads on these things.
What?
See this is like the conception we,
the concept we have about these animals,
right?
We just think that they're
just killers and whatever.
Do you ever see the guy and limone of
Costa Rica who had a pet 15 foot crock?
Yeah, they did say that guy's
an asshole. This is crazy.
It's a crazy animal man. It's a
crocs freaked me out. But I like,
I kind of mess when I'm playing.
When I'm playing golf.
I played a lot of golf when I'm in
Florida. I always messed with the gators.
Like I'll grab him by the tail.
Why? Oh, why? Oh it's, it's kind of,
I dunno. It's just like, it's fun
until you get your arm bid off I guess.
But this guy is not even where he
doesn't even need to backstep you know,
he's like, well those are smaller. Yeah.
But that means still get rip
your arm off death roles.
But that's so small in
comparison to those other ones.
I was fishing in Australia
in this fresh water a river,
but it goes down to the ocean.
So salt water crocs come
up it to a certain point.
There's like this dam and they don't
go past that. So you know, down here,
up here is all the fresh water
down here is fresh and salt water.
And we saw a few 15 foot crocs this day
and we're in a boat that was six feet
wide and about 18 feet long,
15, 18 feet long. And, um,
you know, the guy taking us, he said, you
know, we don't have problem in this boat,
but you know, if you fell out of
the boat there's a book of problem.
But he was telling us a story.
One day I was fishing with these guys
and swing guy standing up in the boat
fishing.
He falls out of it and the guy was about
250 pounds or something like a big dude,
like maybe 300 pounds.
He was like a big overweight guy and
he fell at the boat and the guy said,
the guy was in the water for about two
minutes and he was just like any second,
this guy is dead. He's like,
there's nothing I can do.
And he said it was all they could do to
hit dead to get him from the front of
the boat.
He was trying to pull up,
come up the side and he couldn't and
he was panicking. So He's, you know,
when people go into panic mode,
like when people are drowning
and they're panicking,
they say you've got to punch him in the
face and try to knock them out and call
them down. And they couldn't
punch this guy. Like they would,
they were trying to get them to calm down
and they had to get him all the way to
the back of the boat because they
had to get him up the transom.
And they said from there they could get
leverage and lifted and it wouldn't flip
the boat or whatever.
Right.
But he said this guy was in the water
for a couple minutes and he's like,
at any time there's a croc that's big
enough to eat you with insight of us here
at all times. But this guy
said that, he said that, um,
the biggest, you know, I said,
what's the biggest one you ever seen?
Cause we've seen 15 foot crocs,
like every 20 minutes, every half
an hour. And we see a 15 foot. Yeah,
no giant freaking cop. Yeah. And
we're, we're fishing. Oh my God. Um,
we, we're efficient for Barrow
Monday. That's a crazy fish. Yeah.
And um, and uh, so we're
fishing for money and,
and I keep thinking like,
I dunno when you've got one in
the line is like a shark bite,
that thing or whatever. And
anyways, we started asking the guy,
what's the biggest one you
ever saw? And he said, Mike,
the biggest one I ever saw was about
28 feet. 20. Yeah. 29 feet maybe.
And he said he's only seen it once and
he saw it from about a kilometer away and
the estimated the size
and he said this guy,
these guys in a helicopter shot at
once and it doesn't stay in the river,
it stays out in the ocean.
And he said, it's so smart,
it knows it's in silty water
where nothing can see it.
There's nothing as big as it is. It owned
its territory, you know, eight feet. Yeah.
And he said that, he said that the back,
we're in the six foot boat and he said,
if this thing, he goes, I tell you
this, how big they are. He goes,
this one would be,
he said if it was under our boat,
it would be sticking out about
four to six feet on either side,
across his backside.
And we're in a six foot wide boat.
So he said it'd be like 15 foot across
the back. It's back. That's how fucked up.
So think of the girth. So something
that big 15 feet across the back.
That's what this guy told me. I don't
know. We didn't see it. Oh my God. Well,
I mean we're seeing, you know, 15 footers
that are like, it's girth close to that.
You know, like a great white, when
you see a 15 foot great white,
it's girth is 15 feet pretty
much. They're so fat. Yeah.
Once they get like 10 feet,
then they start getting fat and a
growth gets about the length them.
So if you see a 15 or 20 foot, 18 foot
great white, and you measure their growth,
it's pretty much their length. How big to
crocs get, I don't know. This guy said,
I don't know,
this guy's claiming it's like must have
made the biggest crock in the world.
But there was one they called
Gus or something in Africa.
I used to go late night,
just youtube this stuff.
When they were saying this
is one that had eaten,
like they think it's eaten
over 102 hundred people and
these villages, oh Geez.
And they think it's like 23 feet
long or something. Well this uh,
Jim Shockey show that I was talking to me
about uncharted. They just offered him,
who's look at that fucking thing?
The Savannah King.
Is that a perspective shot though? Look
how far back those, I know. You wonder.
You wonder. Yeah, but people do
that with pigs and then make them,
I do that with my 20. When I catch
a fish, I put it right by the Lens.
It says 28 feet, four inches. So that
makes sense. Like, Oh, what's that?
That's a replica of how big it was.
Fuck that thing. Fuck that thing.
And everything that was alive before
that made dinosaurs too. You know,
like go back to that picture Jamie.
That replica,
make that larger the replica and just
make that larger look at the size of that
fucking thing.
Oh
well what is the largest confirmed ones?
Cause if that one is 28 feet, four
inches, this thing, the thing about that,
when they said 28 feet,
four inches,
that's like back when people
were full of Shit. Yeah.
I mean this guy who told me this Aussie
guy might have been trying to freak me
out too. I mean cause it echo.
Look at that one right there.
That thing is 20 feet and it's not
20 feet across his back or 12 feet.
You know what I mean? Another
eight foot long. It's pretty.
That's why you see when you see like a
five foot crop or alligator and then you
see a 10 foot,
the girth relative to the length changes
at that point is it's like he's talking
about the ratio in the size. It's like
one point, right. What does it say?
Number one, what does it
say? Number one candidate.
This is a list of the top 10 so I
think their largest chronic program,
the Cambodia crocodile seven minutes.
Now is this just the,
the species they're talking about?
Yeah.
This is just the five largest
crocodiles ever recorded on Cambodia.
Show the picture of the Cambodian
one 23 feet. That doesn't have, no,
it doesn't this.
There's only one that had a picture that
would you not take a picture of a 23
foot long crocodile? Trust
me, bro. Schumann's big.
Yeah, I mean I would imagine that
there's probably bigger ones out there.
I know there was a super killer croc
that went extinct that far dwarfed those.
Those were 60 feet are giant.
Enormous.
I had extinct pull up that
extinct giant crocodile.
I had a friend who was a
commercial fisherman and
South Africa and he was like,
he told me, he's like, boot the biggest
shocks it way bigger than you think.
He's like, yeah, and I go, I want to
see a picture or something. He said,
I'll tell you this.
I was on a 60 foot boat with
10 guys fishing almost. Hey.
He said like everybody in
the boat saw the shark.
He said at camp next to their boat,
they were 20 miles off of Port
Elizabeth where there's this reef,
they fish and he's claiming the thing
was more than half the length of their 60
foot boat. Why? He's like it was
35 feet. That's what he tells me.
What is the biggest great white like 20
but he's saying there's Jacques Cousteau
supposedly filled one in Cape Verde did.
They didn't have anything.
They couldn't tell the size cause
they didn't have something next to it.
He said it was close to 10 meters,
which is 30 feet. But this guy,
this guy's telling me,
he goes, no, he goes,
I've seen the shark twice out there
is what he told me, but I don't know.
They're out there every day.
That's the thing. How many
people are out there? Yeah,
I don't know know.
It's like people are the biggest ones.
The biggest ones are smart. You know,
like I don't, I rarely said big shark.
Rarely I'll see like I've seen a couple
of great whites in South Africa jump.
Look at that thing, that that is the, a
replica of something that used to exist.
12 animals.
You're glad it's fucking skull.
This guy's basically standing inside
the skull. This crocodile. So freaky.
Fuck that man. Well that's that. That's
the premise of that stupid movie. The Meg,
meg, meg, Donna. I won't
even watch it. It's like,
oh come, I don't know. Do you
remember that movie? That deep blue?
Is that what it's called? And it was a
shark that they were, there were sharks.
They were training. They
were like GMO sharks are, so
he's genetically clone charts and they
were supposedly training them and then
they got too smart and they start
eating everyone. And then there's like,
you know,
the girls got a hot girl in the Bikini
and she has to take off her wetsuit
because it's rubber. I
don't know. There's the,
you see these movies
and you just like the,
the artistic license on these things
are so bizarre. There's no truth to it.
It's like was here we go. And he started
talking about it. He goes, you know what?
You know what dangerous waters,
not dangerous. Ice is dangerous
fight mall.
We're going to pull together
and we're going to find a way,
good move and see that. I mean I wouldn't,
I wouldn't see that coming at all.
I wouldn't go in the Waterford
seconds after that. So that movie,
I actually was with Samuel L.
Jackson like two weeks ago in Paris.
No one in golf together. How big I wanted
to ask him about that, but I didn't,
I didn't know the balls.
I mean,
how big do you think they
could be and people don't know.
I mean 30 feet sounds reasonable.
If they think they're 25 feet,
there could be one that's 30 feet maybe.
Yeah.
I mean I think it's reasonable to go,
but that's a lot more years and eating
and like no one saw it during that time.
I mean, it's kind of like Ufo
is I got to see one. Yeah,
I got to see an alien sharks and we
know they get big and we're not just how
many people are out there looking for
them. That's the thing. But they film one,
they called big blue last year I think
in Guadalupe Island, I think it was.
And it was 20 is one or two feet. Yeah,
the videos online and it's, you know,
I'm big day look right?
Yeah.
This thing's face and nose look
small because the body is so huge.
It must have been a pregnant
female or something,
but it's body looks like even
bigger around than the length.
And they said it was 20
see like his face almost looks like small.
Oh my God is so,
so world's largest shark.
Seven meters. So that's
2022 feet, 23 feet.
What the, this guy touches it to their
guy comes out of the cage and touches it.
Oh look at this size of this
thing. That's another thing. This,
the shark feeding freaks me out.
There's this guy touched at wash.
He just comes out and he's like,
I gotta touch this creature.
Got To get out of there,
bitch. But she like,
it's face almost like small
compared to how it's so massive.
So scary. That is so big.
It looks like a whale.
It literally looks like a whale.
Oh my God.
And to think that there's something out
there that's 10 feet bigger than that,
well a killer whale can eat that
things liver without thinking about it.
And it it killer whales,
just a dolphin.
It's so weird to think that that thing
has dominance over that thing. It is,
but there's just so much smarter.
Yeah. There's so much more agile,
so much smarter. How often,
what this is a seven guilt,
what do they call that?
Greenland. Shark. Yeah.
They think isn't wasn't that one of
the speculations of what the Loch ness
monster was?
I think there was a,
some sort of a land lock green or not
landlord wouldn't have been in the lock.
Now they think it was the lock because
it was trapped because of the luxury used
to be connected to the guy
was a twig that was good.
The driftwood man. Or it could be like
a sturgeon or some shit like that.
Like there was one of, one of those, um,
was a lake Champlain or one
of those surgeons are here.
Sturgeons are crazy. Yeah. That's a,
that's another diet. So alligator, Gar,
you seeing those things come and
my friends went fishing for them.
They haven't made Texas. You can catch
them in Texas. Those things are bizarre.
I don't think you're noodling for
those things. No. That's another thing.
A hundreds of millions of years
old. Right? I mean that would be,
I'd love to go take my
friends and just go new Lynn.
Sometimes it sounds kind of creepy or
girlfriend be like, what? Noodly oh,
for catfish. Yeah, but, but you get
accidentally get turtle sometimes though.
Snapping turtles and bite your arm
off when it will fuck your Harry's.
I feel fucking hand job. We just break
your arm in half. Probably. Fuck you up.
I mean, I'm sure dudes are probably
lost fingers snapping turtle or those.
What's that?
Accidentally googled that and the
snapping turtle incidents popped up.
Guys losing their hands.
Don't show me this because
that's like two razors.
They're like two razors that go.
Yeah,
like garden sheers taking
your fucking arm off.